the pines beach regeneration area lies
approximately four kilometers east of
kaiapoi just over one kilometer north of
the waimakariri river mouth and about
600 meters from the coastal marine area
from Rinaldi Avenue travelling in a
southerly direction along duns Avenue
the area's on both sides of Don's Avenue
as far along as K Avenue have been
identified as council reserve land with
the potential for private lease of some
of the area with the restriction on any
permanent building on the land further
south along Dunn's Avenue across the
road from the pines oval a similar land
use has been identified as far south as
Chester Street the area on the right
hand side of Dan's Avenue traveling
south has been identified as suitable
for recreation and an ecological linkage
area on the two hi Tyra coastal park
side of pines oval an area has been
identified as suitable for possible
amalgamation with a tu hi Tyra coastal
park this also applies for the areas
south of Chichester street on the left
hand side of Dan's Avenue through 22 hi
Tara kuraki an area of approximately
five point eight hectares is on
Featherston avenue between pines beach
and the waimakariri river mouth and is
separated from the coast by the two high
Tyto coastal reserve traveling in a
southerly direction along Featherston
Avenue towards the waimakariri sailing
and parmer Club the area to the left of
the road has been identified as suitable
for amalgamation into two high Tyto
coastal park beyond that area and closer
to 2i Tata is an area of council owned
land the council supports discussion on
this land also being amalgamated into
the two high Tata coastal park on the
right hand side of Featherston Avenue
the area's highlighted have been
identified as suitable for potential
private lease a smaller area just west
of the kuraki beach car park at the
southern end of Featherston avenue has
been identified as being suitable for
amalgamation into the kuraki car park
reserve we'd like your comments on these
regeneration area proposals for full
details of all the options outlined in
let's plan or to comment on the plan
itself visit the council website why
mackerel egov TN seed or red zone
plantains it or pick up a copy from any
council service center or library